morgen also noch da
ich habe mich alleine nicht vor die
kameras getraut ich habe gerade meinen
vorrednern gelauscht und wenn man den
glauben schenken sollte oder darf dann
steht ja vor ihnen der schlimmste
rechtsausschussvorsitzende der
schlimmste ausschuss vorsitzende des
deutschen bundestages überhaupt seit 70
jahren rege damals an dass sie war
vielleicht ein bisschen faktencheck
betreiben und ich glaube sie werden zu
der auffassung kommen dass dem
mitnichten so ist wir haben viele
unwahrheiten von ihr vorne gehört bei
meinen vorrednern ich hätte brücken
abgebrochen zum deutschen anwaltsverein
der deutsche anwaltsverein hat sich
schon vor meiner wahl positionierten
gesagt der brandner darf es nicht werden
er soll es nicht werden das die brücken
waren niemals da dann wurde auf
nachfrage einen juristinnenbund genannt
der sich gegen mich positioniert hat den
verein kennen überhaupt und wie viel wir
hatten ja keine ahnung
kennst du den juristinnenbund also das
waren die beiden kronzeugen die hier ins
feld geführt wurden
die altparteien haben sich dramatisch
blamiert heute und sie haben diesen
meine kritik an udo lindenberg und frank
walter steinmeier zunächst dazu genutzt
einen medien sturm gegen mich zu
entlassen das war der judaslohn tweet
inzwischen ist vom judaslohn überhaupt
gar keine rede mehr
und jetzt wurde händeringend versucht
irgendwas zu konstruieren warum wir
haben brandner abwählen wollen warum
woher brander abgewählt weil ich
mitnichten der schlechteste
ausschussvorsitzende war seit 70 jahren
sondern ich vermute mal ich war der
beste
sie wollten einen schiedsrichter ich
habe einen mittelstürmer geliefert und
das konnten die altparteien nicht
ertragen deshalb musste der brandner weg
mit ganz erfundenen dingen wenn ich dann
höre hier ja es würde bei den
verabredungen im ältestenrat bleiben uns
wieder der ausschuss vorsitz zu stehen
meine damen und herren das ist blanke
heuchelei
wir haben eine geschäftsordnung des
deutschen bundestages da steht drin die
fdp fraktion hat anspruch ein
bundestagsvizepräsidenten er wird nicht
gewählt wir haben an
wir haben einen einstimmigen beschluss
des deutschen bundestages aus der ersten
sitzung drucksache 19 schrägstrich 3 da
ist einstimmig beschlossen worden vom
deutschen bundestag ein vizepräsident
pro fraktion es wird keiner gewählt und
die altparteien wiegen es sich hin wie
sie wollen
in einem konkreten fall sind mehrfache
brüche der geschäftsordnung die seit
mehreren jahrzehnten nicht zu beklagen
waren geschehen zuletzt jetzt der § 127
geschäftsordnung der angeführt wurde der
geschäftsordnungsausschuss
hat irgendetwas entschieden die
geschäftsordnung sieht vor es kann ins
plenum genommen werden um das zu
überprüfen
die alle parteien vertreten allen
ernstes die auffassung man könne das ja
auch hinterher überprüfen bevor man das
anwendet also heuchlerischer und rechts
buschiger meine damen und herren geht es
nicht das war heute die dritte
resolution die gegen mich verlesen wurde
in drei ausschusssitzungen ich kann
wieder einmal vor wie so anderem fdj
tribunal muss ich ihnen sagen an das war
das nicht aufschlag machte frau rottmann
die gerade hier vor uns geredet hat die
man irgendwie ein paar seiten vorgelesen
hat dann hätte er vielleicht ein paar
seiten folge lesen herzschlag war auch
mal dran nur von den linken und habe
jetzt für die fdp da hat es wohl nicht
gereicht
mal gucken gegen wen sie resolutionen
vorlesen also wir gehen mit erhobenem
haupt hier raus das ist keine niederlage
das einfach eine all parteien koalition
die sie immer gegen die afg stattfindet
egal was wir machen die wollten mich
weghaben
sie wollen der fdr afd vor schienbein
treten das ist nicht gelungen
ich werde meine ausschussarbeit genauso
wie bisher vernünftig fortsetzen und
vechta wo ist glänzt durch abwesenheit
was er mir vorhin vorgeworfen hatte ich
werde nie da wir werden einmal genau
schauen welche minister zum beispiel in
nächster zeit immer bei debatten im
bundestag da sind und wenn die fünf mal
geführt haben dann werden den
abwahlantrag vielleicht stellen wir mal
gucken wie wir das in zukunft machen ich
bedanke mich für eure aufmerksamkeit ich
hatte schon gesagt ich freue mich auf
die weitere ausschussarbeit und würde
mich freuen wenn auch ihr öffentlichkeit
interesse öfter mal da wäre und unsere
ausschussarbeit auch kritisch begleiten
würde vielen dank am anfang es gibt ja
ich weiß gar nicht wo der skandal ist
die abwehr von der bahnhof ist eine
mischung aus dummheit und ein markt
das ist genau wieso ist der judaslohn in
irgendeiner weise antisemitisch da ist
wohl die volksbildung inzwischen nicht
mehr
also was hier geschehen ist ist eine
zumutung das ist eine zumutung auch für
die demokratie und die parteien der
opposition die das mitgetragen haben
müssen sich natürlich die frage stellen
ob jetzt eben nicht mehr die fraktion
den ausschussvorsitzenden bestimmt
sondern ab jetzt künftig wenn einer
nicht pariert er abgewählt wird
das ist ein tabubruch das hat es in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik noch nicht
gegeben und diesen tabubruch kann man
auch mal gegen andere anwenden und ich
fürchte da werden wir noch viele
diskussionen darüber haben wir haben im
moment konkret erst mal vor in der
fraktion über das weitere vorgehen zu
beraten
was der gaul an muskeln der
antisemitismus seiner gauland ihnen
mulmig wurde
so etwas ist was ist das wort bruders
lohn eines ist dem er ohne frage hat
herr lauterbach gebraucht hat herr cast
gebraucht konnte man in der presse nach
judas und jude hat nichts miteinander zu
tun
christus war jude und die zuhörer waren
wir ganz ehrlich das zeug judas war auch
herausgestellt dass dieser vorwurf nicht
mal mehr von den altparteien verfolgen
wurde
da sind ja zurückgerudert haben
tatsächlich gemerkt da hat unsere
bildung offenbar eine lücke gehabt haben
die altparteien sich gedacht und jetzt
machen wir mal was anderes aber das land
gerade besprochen ist natürlich extrem
gefährlich also wir haben diesen
tabubruch seit 70 jahren endlich endlich
ist ein afd vorsitzender weg aber das
wird natürlich die grundfesten der
arbeit im bundestag erschüttern weil
eine vielzahl von ausschussvorsitzenden
von der opposition kommt eine mehrzahl
und die sind natürlich abhängig von den
jeweiligen mehrheiten in ihren
ausschüssen und die mehrheit der
ausschüsse liegen hat bei der regierung
und ich bei der opposition das heißt man
macht sich so für die nächsten jahre
ausschussvorsitzende gefügig das ist ein
weiterer schritt weg von einer gelebten
demokratie hin zu einer demokratie oder
zu einer entwicklung die ich mir nicht
vorstellen konnte bisher aber diese
entwicklung negativ weg von der
demokratie wird immer schlimmer und ich
kann nur sagen wehret den anfängen und
bleiben sie als presse vor allem
kritisch oder werden sie wieder kritisch
geringer und münster gibt es keinerlei
bestrebungen sie abzuwehren
jeder sucht sich hat einen aus jetzt ist
der brandner weg und dann kommt der
nächste dran das ist doch eine ganz
übliche salamitaktik die hier verfolgt
wird wie sie immer schon waren sie
plötzlich die erste scheibe
[Musik]
eine schön
die anderen oppositionsparteien haben
natürlich angst davor aber wenn sie mich
mal anschauen im deutschen bundestag es
gibt keine oppositionsparteien im
klassischen sinne mehr es gibt eine
einheitsfront von dunkelrot bis
schwarz-gelb irgendwo da wird
untereinander genau zu schauen sich
diese peinlichen auftritte anwender
schluss unfähigkeiten im bundestag
festgestellt werden sollen wo ja auch
ein oppositionsvertreter im sitzungssaal
statt normalerweise sitzt alles immer
einer meinung hauptsache es geht gegen
die afg mit inhalten hat das überhaupt
nichts zu tun
wir grünen werden sie den
ausschussvorsitz hart besetzen mit wem
wer sich den ausschussvorsitz wird die
fraktionen darüber beraten das haben wir
nicht getan wir haben erstmal die
entscheidung aber sie werden das tun ist
weiß ich nicht ob wir das tun wir werden
mit in der fraktion darüber
ergebnisoffen beraten wie social news
eine integre person
wir haben nur integre persönlichkeit
nicht solche fragen vom juristischen
bund
hätte man zur mäßigung auf rufen müssen
es war ja völlig glauben was es ging um
die äußeren anlockte und die wortwahl
hätte ist nicht die möglichkeit gegeben
oder das erstmals seine worte lockt mit
der kinder trotzdem seinem 100 herr
brunner hat sich für den re tweet
entschuldigt im plenum da war ich selber
dabei und die andere geschichte nochmal
ist in keiner weise in irgendeiner weise
angreifbar das ist nun mal ein begriff
judaslohn und das haben auch andere
gebraucht von daher sehe ich nicht eine
mitschuld und ich sehe auch nicht für
was sich herr brand munter brauchen wir
entschuldigen soll
sie habe aber das ist jetzt alles
ziemlich konstant ja ermäßigt sich schon
stark was glauben sie wer gemäßigt heute
auf aber es war noch mal der klassiker
my name nicht morgen schon mal gesagt
deutschland merkel staat 2009/10 sie
sagen ihre meinung schwupps ist der job
weg
es geht nicht nur uns so nicht nur mehr
als ausschussvorsitzenden so es geht
draußen dutzenden hunderten menschen
fast jeden tag so die ihre meinung sich
nicht mehr trauen zu sagen und wenn sie
die sagen dass abmahnungen auf sie
herein prasseln dass der job weg ist das
ist gelebte demokratie in deutschland
vielfalt und toleranz und pluralismus
denken bevor gebetet wird von der
gesammelten schar der altparteien wie
als afg leben dass die anderen lagern
nur drüber und leben es nicht es ist
schade und dieses land
jetzt in den letzten 53 lebensjahren
oder ich habe nicht alles richtig
gemacht
außerdem sachen die ich eingeräumt habe
das war dieser geriet im zusammenhang
mit halle gibt es keinerlei anlass für
mich das kritisch zu reflektieren zumal
ja auch die ausschussarbeit nicht
ansatzweise von irgendjemand in frage
gestellt wurde
also für die ja unsinn was meine
vorredner gerade erzählt hatten wir
haben über 71 sitzung jetzt sehr gut
zusammengearbeitet aus der cdu/csu aus
der spd sogar kamen sprüche zu mir die
sachen gut dass frau künast das nicht
mehr macht der berater sollte sie in
diesen sie das machen ist das ja alles
viel professioneller aber davon wollen
natürlich heute nichts mehr wissen
verstehe ich auch ist so ich arbeite
jetzt der dritte 10 uhr geht es bei uns
weiter wo wir sind schon über die zeit
ich hoffe da habe ich angefangen ohne
mich bedanken für die aufmerksamkeit so
weit oder wir sind damals meine vielen
dank